holidays are here which means you guys
want my bed me recipe this is my dad's
recipe it has that crunchy skin on the
outside and that juicy meat on the
inside so let's get into it so the first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to lift that skin up and we are going to
poke holes in our roast pork you're then
going to start working on your delicious
marinade which is simple it's garlic oil
sorito a ton of spices and then you're
going to take that marinade and rub it
all underneath the skin you're going to
make sure you get garlic in those holes
you're going to get the back and when
you're me is fully marinated it's going
to look like this for the top of the
skin we're just going to use saon and
salt and you want to make sure that you
really Pat it dry you let this marinate
overnight and the next day you're going
to pop it in the oven at 350° for the
first few hours once your meat looks
like this you are then going to crank up
the heat so you got that crispy Quito
and guys full recipes on Tony
recipes.com try this out and let me know
what you think